you read the title you all know what's
coming do ya - a critic you are scrotum
of existence and you made some more
fuck-ups Hey
here to point them out hey you're pretty
good at this maybe I should be my own
truck oh all I would have left in is
leaving comments on YouTube but that's
where today's real philosophers are so
we gear up for part three but yes this
is the Tempe Evan dystocia critic
fuck-ups point three Revenge of the shit
wouldn't it technically be Return of the
Jedi
yeah how come everybody always makes
that mistake the returning Jedi is part
stage Revenge of the Sith is part three
just because it came out six doesn't
mean God
everything
number one
your countless Disney sin bear fuck-ups
okay I'm going a little bit out of
character here just to talk about the
few mistakes I made in Disney Center
granted most of its nitpicking but
that's what we're here I'll go through
the ones that were brought up the most
in my Aristocats review I see that the
butler is going to inherit the cat and
he wants to get rid of them because he
hates cats
well technically that's true except I
forgot to mention that the cat we're
going to inherit all the riches and once
they're out of the picture
the butler went here at the money okay
does that really make the film any
stronger I guess it gives him more
reason to kill them but who leaves money
to cast it's just stupid next is in both
rescuer movies I say that miss Bianca is
played by Zsa Zsa Gabor when actually it
was her sister hey buck amore honestly
I'm just impressed that my fan base knew
who either of these women were I must
have more Greenacres fans than I thought
another is that I say the friends and a
goofy movie are going to a concert when
really they were just watching it at
home it was just max who said he was
gonna appear at the concert on TV again
a minor mess-up but the one that people
really freaked out over was when I
called the leopard in Tarzan a cheetah
yes I never knew people were so feline
savvy but yes that would make this kitty
a leopard it's a cat it has spots
whatever again minor mistake but they're
worth bringing up minor Julie I get if I
call these things a rabbit a turtle a
good Super Bowl campaign I wouldn't
psychiatry's do have to go to medical
school you have an axe I think most
people knew what I meant by this but it
is still technically a fuckup
I was referring to him my patch Adams
roomy with that the character they were
portraying would be much better learning
to be a psychiatrist as opposed to a
doctor who performed operations but
either way you still got to go to
medical school which I reacted strangely
to when I heard that he was in the movie
I didn't mean to indicate that
psychiatrists are doctors they still had
to know the biological psychological and
social aspects of a patient that way
they can tell if the problem is
metabolic or psychiatric I was referring
more than a man who does nothing but act
like bozo that jackass would be more
fitted away from the sharp medical tools
unless they're being used to stab him
I'm also told that bedside manner wasn't
at its best even back then but I still
have my doubts that the way these
doctors talk was the norm I mean they
were pretty much saying that all doctors
back then were acting like oh that and
that just doesn't seem as logical would
it make more sense if you're a nice
doctor that you would get more patients
that they would want to come and see you
that they would prefer you over doctors
who are mean did patch Adams really come
and transform this I had my suspicions
but yeah my to talk about a time period
where I wasn't even a sperm unit
on the plus side at least we don't have
to put up with that horrible doctor
bitch spasms again yeah I think he
thought he's gonna come in do something
funny but nope
I shot him he's dead he's right there
lying on the floor every we should do
something about that corpse
you shouldn't review Thomas the Tank
Engine if you haven't seen the show okay
look I made it very clear that I never
saw this show I was only reviewing the
movie based on the fact that a lot of
people want me to review it and for the
most part people liked it but to all
those people saying I need to see the
show before I judge the movie I'm here
to make jokes calm the fuck down never
viewed movies based on shows I haven't
seen before like the Pokemon movie The
Avengers heck even the original Star
Trek shows I barely seen and I can still
get through the movies okay I'm just
judging by what's given to me as a movie
goer maybe it is made only for people
who watch the show in which case I get
the feeling I would like the show even
less but sometimes part of the fun is
not knowing about it and being really
confused that's what made a lot of
people enjoy the Pokemon review now if I
said the show sucked despite the fact I
never saw it then I can understand
getting angry but when I openly
acknowledge I've never seen it now I
think it just makes for funnier moments
when I don't know what's going on I also
hear some people were angry that I was
shocked that big names like Alec Baldwin
and Peter Fonda we're in this when Bing
named George Carlin was on the original
show well Peter Fonda and Alec Baldwin
for the most part were still doing big
dramatic roles at that time I love
George Carlin but he was doing Tarzan
too and scary movie 3 the shock values
kinda take him down a few notches after
you do that but he's still awesome what
are the words
Kip his fuck cunt cocksucker
motherfucker tits fart turd and twat now
if that wasn't Thomas the Tank Engine I
probably liked
pee-wee's fluid dick talk in pee-wee's
Playhouse yes in another top 11 list the
top 11 nostalgic mind fucks I say that
the intro to pee-wee's Playhouse is well
uh nostalgic my fuck however I say at
one point that the only thing that never
taught was the floor well I was wrong
apparently even the floor got up to say
a few lines every once in a while in
fact he even had a name his name was
Florrie and I swear I don't know how I
forgot him now because of this a lot of
people have been accusing me of being an
anti ground aight well let me tell you
something I have nothing against
hard-working floors sure they're taken
for granted sure we walk over them all
the time but that doesn't mean they
don't have feelings too many my good
friends are floors if I die have a good
relationship with my floor here isn't
that right how apparently floors can
fire guns I did not know that Creek the
holding that thing
Seren couldn't fly into the nexus
because his ship would explode clad in
my Star Trek generations review I asked
why the bad guy Sauron could just buy a
ship and fly it into the Nexus would you
just save up your money and be like
shuttle please my god that was easy
hello Nexus how are you hey well there
actually is a line that explains why
I've seen you just fly into it with a
ship my records show that every ship
which is approached the ribbon has
either been destroyed or severely
damaged okay so a ship can't fly into it
but still aren't there other creative
ways he could have pulled this off like
aren't there still space suits in the
future if he knows where it's going
can't he just work his way out of it and
wait for it to hit him and then the ship
behind him would be destroyed he'll they
still have beaming devices can't they
just beam him in a space suit out to the
Nexus and then leaded him there just has
to be easier ways but nevertheless my
theory of flying a ship into the Nexus
technically doesn't work now I know what
you're thinking aren't there one or two
other strobes in your Star Trek
insurrection review hm
there's a commentary boom go listen to
it sorry about some of the audio issues
Denton's innate Nachum monkey as you can
probably tell right now I'm not exactly
an animal expert I can't tell a cheetah
from the leopard and I can't tell a
monkey from an ape and orangutan to be
more specific but to be honest monkey
just sounds funnier I don't care if it's
wrong I'll still call him a monkey I
need to think about imagine if Planet of
the Apes was replaced by Planet of the
monkeys would you be laughing your ass
off at that title or imagine if the
monkeys were called the Apes that's not
nearly as life whatever is he's still
not funny sometimes the choice of words
can determine whether or not you get a
laugh lettuce for example it's not funny
cabbage is frigging hilarious
what lettuce cabbage fucking funny and I
know that monkeys and apes technically
aren't the same thing but again lettuce
cabbage he always works pretty basic
he's not a monkey next
tapping under windows can you will you
insensitive prick cock
yeah I'm finding out so much about
animals today in my free Willie review I
point out that I don't really see the
major problem in kids banging on the
window of a whales pen blood it turns
out because their sound is amplified not
only does it sound louder but they can
also interpret it as danger it can cause
stress lower their immune system and
even kill them Wow
where the hell is the whale lady on that
one I mean she was like well the
caretakers wasn't she should it be a
sign don't hit the glass like little
idiots I mean I didn't know this will
make something that little kids would
should there be a person down there with
something making sure that people don't
do this I mean kids do all sorts of
stupid things they watch this for crying
out loud but again I can't blame the
movie technically for this mistake
it's still my own that is why you failed
no come on you didn't know that
didn't I though didn't I know what
you're on the internet and as we all
know all information from the internet
is supposed to be right you know douchey
it just hit me
won't you come on board as a fact
checker oh we're not because they're
really thinking about it though
that's it Pat not a bad you still be
stupid so on top of knowing little about
animals apparently I know little about
cluck where as well in my Gordie review
I refer to a pan as being a pot honestly
I just always assumed they were kind of
the same thing but nope one has a handle
the other doesn't pretty basic and I'm
aware I should know better
just don't let Gordon Ramsay know I did
this oh oh oh come on I'm sure a
lobbyist comes from spending less time
in the kitchen and more time eating
sugar frosted burrito stuff hot pockets
oh and love those with the extra yard on
this day yeah I know Anthony butter
taken from real liposuctions and the
side of oil that's found in most er
cameos yes those are the best bit I love
them I love them Johnny oh how dare we
always find something in common nothing
too much to say about this one except
honestly I just need to spend more time
around the stone well maybe not too
your let's play parts nightmare need i
say more
okay a lot of people I'm sure want to
see this as number one but really when
you get down to it nothing technically
or factually is wrong here it just
turned out to be a really bad video but
with that said yeah it's a pretty bad
video I guess I was just too behind the
times of how Let's Plays work and what's
appropriate to put in them and boy does
it show this is up there with Melvin as
one of my biggest balls it's easily one
of the most despised videos because I
don't get the let's play the proper time
and respect it deserves now to be fair
that was sort of part of the joke
tackling something that I thought was
more simple but it turns out it was much
more difficult than I thought
unfortunately though the punchline just
didn't play out people got real tired
real fast and it's still considered to
be one of the worst nostalgia critics I
didn't have to spend half of my next
review just apologizing for it now
that's gotta be bad but really guys
don't worry I know you're gonna love my
let's play of Luigi's Mansion
Billa didn't want to marry Edward in
Twilight you wore hard yes when I put
Bella in my top 11 dumbasses in distress
I brought up that among her other faults
she was pressuring Edward into marriage
actually I got it the other way around
it was Edward that was pressuring her
into marriage because really ladies
isn't that a common problem men
pressuring you into marriage which is so
obsessed with commitment I guess I got
confused by the fact that she was
pleading him to turn her into a vampire
which from the sounds of it is a much
bigger and even dangerous commitment so
I figured marriage after asking that
wouldn't be such a big deal but nope
apparently living her life as a blood
sucking beast of the night for the rest
of her life she's absolutely sure about
but be legally bound together that's
obviously the much bigger issue that
takes a lot more time and don't get me
wrong it is a big issue and it does take
time but she just hears the word vampire
and she's like I'm in I'm in what
whoever's idea was it still makes both
of them look like jackasses but still
fess up when you mess up it was Edward
who wanted to get married not Bella I
guess that means we can like her now
right and the number one this - Critic
fuck up part three is
your complete misunderstanding of the
planet cyclo this one I get a ton of
emails about and to be honest I can see
why in my Battlefield Earth review I
mentioned how it seems incredibly
unlikely that an explosion wouldn't
happen on their planet to set off an
atmosphere that was radioactive
especially seeing how violent they were
but actually the air was a reactive gas
not radiation nuclear radiation is what
would set it off and the explosion isn't
just an explosion it's a nuclear
explosion which I guess they're building
up that the cycles never came across or
tested out we even referenced this in my
Star Trek insurrection it was at the air
they breathed reacted violently to
radiation it's ironic because this
brought on one of my biggest outbursts
but in reality it actually wasn't caught
so the facts about why the planet really
blew up are actually for the most part
totally legitimate but I still must ask
how can it advanced weapon savvy violent
race not have come up with nuclear
fusion again these things are apparently
soon advanced and so goddamn violent
happy that you know they would have come
up with something that can be as harmful
as nuclear fusion these guys look for
anything destructive anything hazardous
and yet somehow we the more peaceful
planet came up with nuclear fusion and
they didn't I'm sorry
I saw the hard time believing it it's
just open
forget it dr. gray you can't are your
way up Wow this will be really did a
number on you didn't you know what I'm
just gonna be painting his page
he's the Nostalgia Critic he remembers
easy
again